leading a tour through jerusalem's
holocaust memorial yad bashem
is always special for jonathan matthews
today the young israeli researcher
is guiding a group of israeli school
children
with its monumental architecture and
powerful exhibition
it's a place like no other to learn
about the showa
generally speaking the whole concept of
telling the story in this museum
and perhaps connecting different
generations toward the holocaust
is by focusing on the victim and when i
say focus on
the dictum we have naturally historical
information museum but we also have
personal artifacts and video testimonies
of survivors
the individual stories of the victims
are an essential part of the museum
making the horrors of the show a
tangible over 75 years later
the increasingly elderly survivors are
slowly disappearing
that poses a challenge with the museum
educational programmes its comprehensive
archive
and a large collection of documents yad
vashem aims to keep the victims memories
alive
the exhibition also deals with the nazis
rise to power
totalitarian regimes and anti-semitism
an issue that's just as relevant today
this is a topic that worries me
anti-semitism and a holocaust denial
and this is one of the reasons i believe
that it's important for me to work here
as an individual but also i think it
demands more
active involvement of different
governments in the world to deal with
this problem
the hall of names many victims never
left a trace
never had a headstone or a grave it's a
memorial for all of the six million
murdered jews
young israelis often learn about the
holocaust through their own family
histories
annual memorial services and school from
the age of 16
school groups usually go to yad vashem
but a visit like this
is never easy
[Music]
you can see and hear many artifacts from
that period
and it's really tough for me
i think it's very important to conserve
this because people need to know what
happened
and to prevent this from happening in
the future again
and to show that even in hard times
there were people who kept up their
hopes
and helped others and tried to survive
a place to reflect on what happened over
75 years ago
and a commitment to keeping that memory
alive for generations to come
so roseanne and michelle are still with
me roseanne we saw what they're doing in
israel trying to keep the memory alive
for the
for young generations have you yourself
been to yad bashes of course and what
was it like
it's a mandatory stop for every
elementary school uh kid in israel
well not before 1314 but there's
everybody go so it's a very
you know yad vashem stands for yad which
is a hand and a
name uh hashem uh for each and every
uh of the fallen six million victims so
it's just part of of of you know it's
sort of the
the end point of a long
engagement with that as a student in
israel of course we have also the annual
memorial day for
where where there's a there's a moment
of silence with
mentioned by sirens in israel where you
stop and you take the time to think and
connect with that israel has managed
throughout the years to make the
the the holocaust and the stories of the
victims accessible to
very young children from very young age
um in very
communicative ways you know if it's anne
frank if it's you know and further on
into the details and stories of kids
throughout the holocaust as
you were young but then as you grow up
further into the stories of what
happened and understanding more of the
historical
meaning of what happened there so um
this is something quite
strong with an israeli narrative as you
grow up um
it's it's it's a part of it it's part of
who you are and part of your upbringing
and michelle what was it uh for you like
growing up here in germany were you
taught about the holocaust
and all the horrors that took place
during the nazi regime while you were at
school
yes this is was an integral part of my
schooling in west germany
although in east germany it was somewhat
a different picture from what
i've learned since and uh clearly an an
aware
awareness was being created of the
historical responsibility but i'd like
also like to come back to something that
frankfurt
schneiderlin the german president said
that one shouldn't forget the
individuals
between behind those very large numbers
more than a million
people died in auschwitz alone and um
today i mean i'm a mother myself and i
struggle to explain to a youngster we
saw those youngsters in that report
there
not just the magnitude of what happened
but that children
were killed there that humans can do
something like that
to each other and that's a very
individual experience
for everyone to let sink in and to
understand
and those very few survivors we still
have now
are telling us that they are seeing
signs again that something like this
could be possible that that's how it all
started
uh looking at these signs of
anti-semitism in europe
that is something that really should not
just let leaders
listen up but everybody in their own
society